[Music]
on this monday night
the unprecedented dependency on canadian
food banks
we are struggling to keep up with that
demand how charities are serving up new
ways to ease growing hunger pains
covet 19's unwelcome comeback in new
brunswick
not the thanksgiving we would have hoped
for the new surge spawning new rules
armenia versus azerbaijan
a failed cease-fire the fighting and the
pointing and lucky ducky
the canadian sleuth who saved the day of
actor john cryer
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
sophie louie good evening and thanks for
joining us
as canadians sit down for thanksgiving
dinner this evening
there are many families turning to food
banks to put a meal on the table
the everyday need for help is growing
with food insecurity in this country
rising dramatically since the start of
the covet 19 crisis
before the pandemic more than 840 000
canadians relied on food banks across
this country
now some are reporting a 25 to 50
percent
increase in demand even higher in some
places
the federal government has allocated 100
million dollars to the emergency food
security fund
as jeff semple reports some
organizations are going to great lengths
to meet the growing need
for food for canadian charities
this is an annual tradition
preparing thanksgiving dinner for the
poor and vulnerable
and this year the demand is daunting in
canada we've never seen food insecurity
to the heights that it is
currently and certainly a lot of that is
caused by the pandemic
we're seeing a lot of new faces
toronto's daily bread food bank has seen
its clientele climb
by more than 200 percent at no
time has the need for food banks been
more pressing
and and we are struggling to keep up
with that demand to meet the moment
some are reconnecting with their roots
this alberta lawyer had never grown
anything before
but his property is vast and when the
pandemic hit
he decided to get his hands dirty the
demand for food at the food bank was
astronomically high and it was like a
light bulb went off for me
a seed of an idea quickly sprouted into
the pandemic planting project
volunteers planting veggies and picking
90 thousand pounds of potatoes
donated to those in need and the
pandemic also presents
another unique challenge how to deliver
all of this desperately needed food and
supplies
safely to that end for the first time in
its history
the food bank is hosting a food drive
drive
through long lines of cars looking
to contribute while others are skipping
the traffic
all together deploying donations
by drone so for the first time ever in
canada
we've launched a humanitarian cargo
drone mission
the charity global medic typically
responds to disasters overseas
but they're now redeploying that help at
home
flying food along with soap and masks to
remote
indigenous communities during covid
there are a lot of restrictions on
travel we have challenges all the time
especially in the winter months getting
supplies to the communities
for the many missing out this long
weekend canadians are finding creative
ways to bring
thanksgiving to them jeff semple global
news toronto
it's the first day to apply for the
canada recovery benefit
one of the replacements for the serb the
500
a week support benefit is for people who
are missing work due to the pandemic
but aren't eligible for employment
insurance many who logged on to the
canada revenue agency website earlier
today to apply for the benefit
reported technical difficulties but the
cra says
those issues have been resolved those
who are approved for the benefit can
access it for up to 26 weeks as for
daily case counts a number of provinces
didn't report today due to
the holiday but here's what we can tell
you there were 843 new infections
reported in quebec today
manitoba reported 77 new cases and there
were 48 in saskatchewan
in atlantic canada there was one new
case in newfoundland and labrador
nova scotia reported zero and there were
six new cases in new brunswick
those newly confirmed infections in new
brunswick bring to 76 the total number
of active infections there
that's a big caseload for a province
that for months
had very few cases as ross lord reports
it's a reminder for people everywhere
now is not the time to be complacent
what's happening in new brunswick shows
just how quickly covid19 can spread
barely a week ago there were three
active cases in this province
now there are 76 active cases roughly
half of them at this long-term care home
in moncton
five people are in hospital one in
intensive care
we've been privileged here in new
brunswick to have uh had some of our
closest contacts with the disease for a
long time being
fear and a bit of anxiety when we see an
outer province licensed blade
but now the disease is here in our
province and active
in the viral hot zones new province wide
rules mandating masks in
indoor public spaces are being expanded
to include the outdoors the government
is urging people not to travel to the
outbreak zones
and it's telling residents who live
there to stay home if possible
the outbreaks which include several
schools have forced many new
brunswickers to scrap their travel plans
for thanksgiving weekend
happy thanksgiving to everyone
not the thanksgiving we would have hoped
for but still a lot to be thankful for
the other three atlantic provinces are
still reporting few
if any new cases including nova scotia
whose land border with new brunswick
remains open and has not
followed the other atlantic provinces in
applying special travel guidelines to
his residents
but the spirit of harmony inside the
so-called atlantic bubble
is in danger of being knocked out of
tune people's
antennae is are are up
um in relation to new brunswick
residents and
we're say cautiously waiting to see what
happens
the next 14 days will be critical in
terms of how we see things unfolding
here
a new level of anxiety in a region that
had been relatively unscathed
ross lord global news in manitoba most
of the people dealing with covet 19
are in the winnipeg area but the virus
has been detected
in some remote first nations communities
too one of them
is little grand rapids first nation near
the northern ontario border
according to the first nation more than
30 people have tested positive
over the weekend the canadian red cross
flew into the community to help with
infection control
and ppe training the red cross also went
to york factory first nation to help
with logistics and ppe training
in ontario an outbreak has been declared
at western university
after four people at the same student
residence tested positive
the university says the outbreak
occurred at london hall
the affected people are now in
self-isolation and contact tracing
is underway to europe now governments
are struggling with how best to get a
hold of the second wave of this pandemic
in places like the uk france and spain
case numbers are skyrocketing and
hospital beds are filling up
but the world health organization is
urging countries to do
everything they can to avoid sweeping
lockdowns
we want to try and avoid and sometimes
it's unavoidable
we accept that but what we want to try
and avoid are these massive
lockdowns that are so punishing to
communities to society
and to everything else now british prime
minister boris johnson says he doesn't
want another national lockdown
but with case numbers spiking in england
he's unveiled a new plan for targeted
restrictions
to help get the situation under control
the three level
alert system will mean tougher measures
for harder hit regions
crystal gomencing has more on how it
will all work
the u.k has more covid covid19 patients
in hospital
now than when britain entered its
national lockdown back in march
with hospital beds filling up three
overflow facilities
are now on standby these figures are
flashing at us like dashboard warnings
in a
passenger jet and we must act
now the north is leading the country in
infections but they are rising fast
across the uk
england is now being divided into a
three-tier alert system
under medium groups are restricted to
six people pubs and bars must close
at 10. most of england will be moving to
the high
level which adds a ban on household
indoor mixing
under very high pubs and bars are closed
and people are asked to limit their
travel areas within the very high alert
category
will be reviewed every four weeks
liverpool city center will be the first
to enter that very high alert level
wednesday
that means pubs and bars will have to
shut down
the hospitality sector has said it is
being unfairly targeted by the
government
the nighttime industries association is
even considering
legal action against the government
there are no plans
at the moment to close schools but
universities have seen large outbreaks
earlier this month northumbria
university reported 770 infections
manchester university at 127 cases in
september
the majority of infections had been in
the 16 to 29 year old population
but older individuals are starting to
fall ill
the elderly suffer a much worse course
with covid19
they are admitted to hospital for longer
periods and they are more difficult to
save
the prime minister says the months ahead
will test the country
but he is confident it will succeed
crystal gomansing global news
london in the u.s despite the pandemic
and
infections on the senate judiciary
committee the confirmation hearing began
today
into president trump's top pick to fill
the supreme court seat of late
justice ruth bader ginsburg judge amy
coney barrett is a staunch supporter of
the religious right
and will solidify a six to three
conservative majority on the nine-member
court
that's why republicans want her
confirmed before the november
third election and why democrats are
determined to stop it
in her opening statement amy coney
barrett said she will stick to the
constitution
but courts are not designed to solve
every problem
or right every wrong in our public life
when the president offered me this
nomination i was deeply honored
i chose to accept the nomination because
i believe
deeply in the rule of law and the place
of the supreme court
in our nation tomorrow both sides will
have the chance to ask amy coney barrett
questions about whether or not
she is the right candidate for the
supreme court democrats warn the former
law professor will strip away
critical health benefits if successful
including obamacare
still in the u.s president trump is back
on the campaign trail gearing up for
more
crowded campaign rallies late today
trump's physician revealed he has
tested negative for covet 19 on
consecutive days
and trump is once again being slammed by
america's top infectious disease expert
over a new campaign ad dr anthony fauci
says he's been taken out of context
to heat praise on the president jennifer
johnson reports
after repeating misleading information
about his health u.s president donald
trump is back campaigning
telling advisers to get him on the road
every single day until election day
rallies are planned this week in florida
pennsylvania iowa and north carolina
i've been tested totally negative
seven days after returning to the white
house after being hospitalized for covet
19
the white house has finally released a
memo from the president's physician
saying he has tested negative on
consecutive days
but medical experts question that it's
very difficult
to know if someone is infectious or not
with the current test
we still need better and more
appropriate testing in the country
on twitter trump claimed i can't get it
immune and can't give it
but twitter took the tweet down saying
it had misleading and potentially
harmful information
this as a new ad put out by the trump
campaign is drawing fire from the
nation's top infectious disease expert
dr anthony fauci president trump tackled
the virus head-on
as leaders should i can't imagine that
anybody could be
doing more dr fauci says that comment
made
seven months ago was about the
government's response to the pandemic
not the presidents dr fauci writing they
did this without my permission and my
comments were taken
out of context in my five decades of
public service
i have never publicly endorsed nor do i
now endorse
any political candidates the pandemic is
showing a resurgence
across the u.s with three dozen states
reporting an
increase in new cases and several
breaking records
hospitalizations are spiking too his
reckless personal conduct since his
diagnosis
has been unconscionable the longer
donald trump is president
the more reckless he seems to get rising
cases and
deaths of coven 19 now at the forefront
of the presidential campaign
with the election just three weeks away
jennifer johnson global news
washington a cease-fire crumbles almost
immediately after it begins coming up
why concern is growing over conflict
in the caucuses plus the b.c man who
answered actor john cryer's
cry for help
china is denying the two canadians held
for almost two years have been
arbitrarily detained
in response to the arrest of huawei
executive mangwon joe
its foreign ministry spokesperson says
china firmly opposes the erroneous
statements made by canada
and reiterated its claim that michael
kovrig and michael svavor
are suspected of endangering china's
national security
the two michaels were both granted
consular access in recent days the first
time since january
kobrig's wife told the cbc he was
relieved to get outside news
and shock to learn about the scale of
the coronavirus pandemic
a ceasefire between armenia and
azerbaijan didn't last
long both sides accusing the other of
breaking the truce almost as soon as it
began over the weekend
hundreds of soldiers and civilians have
died in the fighting over the disputed
region
of nagorno-karabakh and as redmond
shannon reports
there are now fears the conflict could
escalate and draw in regional powers
like turkey and russia
orphaned by war these azerbaijani
siblings lead a funeral procession
for their parents they were among nine
people killed according to azerbaijan
by armenian bombing coming shortly after
a ceasefire brokered by russia
over the weekend what we see here is
just armenia's purpose to kill
civilians once again shows a true face
of armenia
armenia says the accusation it targeted
civilians is an
absolute lie the problem might be that
azerbaijan
very often um resorts to well
they choose to locate their military
positions in uh
close to residential areas i don't know
but we never we never target
a peaceful population armenia says it
was azerbaijan
backed by turkish military support that
broke the ceasefire minutes
after it came into effect and if turkey
previously has been a kind of behind the
scenes
player in azerbaijan's domestic and
foreign policy now they're really
hands-on
turkey has denied numerous reports it's
recruited syrian mercenaries to fight
alongside azerbaijani forces
nagorno-karabakh is part of an
armenian-controlled region which is
internationally recognized as part of
azerbaijan
after the two countries became
independent war in the 1990s killed
tens of thousands of people until a
delicate truce was reached
analysts believe years of neglect by
foreign powers who oversaw the deal
have led to the renewed hostilities
armenia's foreign minister was in moscow
to meet his russian counterpart on
monday
he also pointed to a lack of independent
monitoring of the region
russia's foreign minister dismissed
calls for turkey to be more involved in
brokering a peace deal
last week canada suspended some arms
exports to turkey over allegations
equipment was being passed on to
azerbaijani forces
canadian foreign minister francois
philippe champagne is in europe this
week
and will discuss the conflict with nato
and eu leaders
redmond shannon global news london
still ahead how an adoption agency's
financial fumbles cost the dreams of
some prospective parents
adopting a child comes with many hurdles
security checks
parenting courses a huge financial cost
and
there are no guarantees a number of bc
families found that out the hard way
paying thousands to an agency they had
assumed was being overseen by the
provincial government
but it suddenly shut down in 2019 and as
robin gill reports
one prospective parents detective work
uncovered problems that went back
years there are children in this world
who need a home and there are families
like corey bell and her husband
who want to adopt i have like no
specific desire to have biological
children so i always thought i'd do it
the 38 year old turned to choices
adoption a victoria charity
she spent twelve thousand dollars to
have social workers
interview her and take courses on taking
on a child
that isn't hers biologically then the
agency suddenly closed last year
with no recourse for belle who was among
90 families
left in the lurch it has been very
devastating
i mean it's it's
a hard enough thing adopting it's
a lot you do background checks and
classes and
you wait but to feel like you aren't
haven't been supported
by your government like you've been
abandoned
by a charity organization it's
devastating
before choices shut down it asked and
got
90 000 from the province to pay its
debts
bell uncovered documents she feels
should have been red flags
and filed a complaint with the
provincial ombuds person
the financial documents that we got a
hold of do
show a lot of very unnecessary travel a
lot of very expensive coffees
there was a very fancy 25th anniversary
party
that was paid for by adoptive parents
not by the government
not by charity donations it was paid for
by me
but there was never an audit of any of
these expenses
when the troubles of this adoption
agency became apparent
the ministry in charge of adoptions in
this province said it would step
in but it's been close to a year and the
families
are still waiting bc is in the midst of
a provincial election so no one from the
government will comment
some families turn to victoria police to
file a complaint citing financial
mismanagement and fraud
the police department couldn't confirm
if there's an investigation
the families were told they could have
their files transferred to two other
agencies that still
operate in british columbia i would
still love to adopt but i don't see how
it's possible
in this scheme i can't just keep
throwing money down a hole
but it means starting all over again and
the emotional burden
has already been too much robin gill
global news
victoria up next wyatt vancouver man
is now king of the ring in the eyes of a
hollywood star
american actor john cryer has something
pretty special to be grateful for this
canadian thanksgiving
the star known for his role in the
sitcom two and a half men
is working in vancouver he was walking
along the city's sea wall when he
dropped his wedding ring
after a futile search he called in a
local man who helps people recover lost
jewelry
and then this happened how does this
feel
oh no oh you're kidding me
there you go beautiful man that is
absolutely beautiful
wow thank you that is the one now wait
we have to check it out i have no doubt
boom
took to twitter with his story in a
lengthy post that's been shared nearly
ten
thousand times he gave thanks to this
guy
saying i am still beside myself this is
chris
he is awesome i got lucky uh
probably three minutes into the search i
found it
in the middle of the grass in a
three-foot area
his reaction it was like most people's
kind of disbelief like
and and shock and surprise and he was
happy
and that's global national for this
monday i'm sophie louis we leave you
tonight with a heartfelt tribute to a
beloved hockey coach
darcy hogan was head coach of the humble
broncos he was killed in the 2018 bus
crash that also took the lives of 15
others
now he's being honored with a new bronze
statue in his hometown of peace river
alberta
thanks for watching and have a great
night happy thanksgiving
[Music]